From his time at Stanford to a congressional run,
Ben Savage has been busy — even if he
doesn’t grace our TV screens as much
these days. So what is the formerly
super famous young actor up to now?
Cory Matthews finally met the world
when Boy Meets World wrapped up in 2000,
and lead actor Ben Savage was ready
to move on. He told Rolling Stone,
"I was 19 at the time and had been on the show
for seven years. I was really
focused on going to college."
And that he did. Savage enrolled at
the prestigious Stanford University,
and he mostly retreated from show business,
only appearing in one major role over the
next six years, in 2002's Swimming Upstream.
At Stanford, Savage surprisingly didn't major
in theater, film, communications, or any other
kind of arts or entertainment-based discipline.
Instead, he pursued a degree in political science,
with a special interest in government and
structure. As many high-achieving college students
do, Savage also supplemented his studies of how
the government works with the kind of prestigious,
high-profile internship that most any political
science major would want: he worked in the
Washington, D.C., office of the late Pennsylvania
senator Arlen Specter. He told Rolling Stone,
"Getting an internship in D.C. is really all about
connections. I thought it
would be a fun experience."
It's not that Ben Savage has completely
disappeared from Hollywood, it's just that
he's not the out-and-out star of a popular
situation comedy anymore. He does, however,
stay in the world of show business by playing the
episodic TV guest-star-of-the-week game. Not only
does that kind of work pay the bills, it also
gives an actor a chance to put his performance
skills to the test, potentially playing a
wildly different character with every new gig.
Savage has really mixed it up, too. He
played a nerdy military engineer on Chuck,
a possible murderer on Without a Trace, a
nasty blogger on the kid-com Shake It Up,
a sketchy lottery winner on
Bones, and as the younger
version of Mandy Patinkin's character on
a flashback episode of Criminal Minds.
"It's never been more important
to catch a guy like this."
If you're over the age of,
say, 20, you're probably most familiar with
Ben Savage for his role as Cory Matthews on
Boy Meets World. If you're under the age of 20,
you know him from reruns of Boy Meets World that
have aired on the Disney Channel for the past 20
years. The show proved so popular that it led to
the network's sequel series called Girl Meets
World. A brief synopsis: Cory and his Boy Meets
World girlfriend Topanga are now adults in their
thirties and the parents of a tween named Riley.
It turns out that going back to the role
that made him famous in the first place
is just what Savage needed. Girl Meets
World ran for 72 highly-rated episodes.
The Disney Channel ended the series in
2017 before it had a chance to get stale.
Somewhere in between a guest-star gig and being
a full-fledged series regular is the casting
status known as "recurring role," in which a
character pops in every few episodes, or a few
consecutive installments as part of a plot arc.
After the demise of Girl Meets World in 2017,
Savage signed up for a stint on a semi-obscure
sitcom called Still the King. It starred Billy
Ray Cyrus as Burnin' Vernon, a scandal-prone
one-hit wonder who can't find any traction
in the music industry and winds up becoming a
drunk-driving Elvis impersonator-turned-church
handyman on parole. It was, in short,
the complete opposite of Boy Meets World,
and yet it attracted Ben Savage, who over the
course of four episodes played Gene, a federal
agent and master of disguise. Unfortunately for
Savage, CMT canceled Still the King in late 2017.
"I'm a porta-potty baby???"
During the relative obscurity between when Boy
Meets World went off the air in 2000 and when
Girl Meets World debuted on the Disney Channel in
2014, Savage made one notable attempt to return
to TV as the star of a primetime show. In 2007,
Savage headlined a lawyer sitcom called Making
It Legal. Created by Freaks and Geeks writer
Jeff Judah, the series would have concerned
two attorneys competing for an open partner
slot at their Chicago firm. Savage stayed
in his wheelhouse, playing a neurotic,
nervous, and eager-to-please young lawyer.
The cast also included Scott Wolf, Ashley
Williams, and Geoffrey Arend. Making It
Legal could have been Savage's big comeback,
and it could have represented a complete break
with his kid-stuff past, but unfortunately the
pilot didn't get picked up for a full series run.
Savage has tried to get a movie career going with
a variety of roles in an array of low-budget,
independently-produced films. While they might
have earned solid reviews and enjoyed modest
audiences at festivals and on home video, they
were small movies in every way, as opposed to
big blockbuster hits or major award winners.
They didn't do much to increase Savage's reach.
Among the interesting but obscure
projects in which Savage starred are:
the addiction/family drama The Caterpillar's
Kimono; the opposites-attract romantic comedy
Girl Meets Boy, the teen cancer tearjerker
Swimming Upstream; and Palo Alto, CA, a dramedy
about four friends reuniting in their hometown
on the first Thanksgiving of their college years.
Ben Savage has a lot in common with his older
brother, Fred Savage. Both got their start as
kid actors and are best known for long-running ABC
sitcoms that became cultural touchstones — Ben for
Boy Meets World, and Fred for The Wonder Years.
They've also both moved behind the camera and
behind the scenes as they aged, choosing to
act less but opting to direct and produce.
Fred Savage has produced a few comedy shows
such as Party Down and Garfunkel and Oates,
and he's directed dozens of half-hour episodes
for shows like The Goldbergs and It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia. Ben Savage has once again
followed his older brother into the family
business. Savage served as a co-producer for more
than four dozen episodes of Girl Meets World,
and he also took the director's chair for 10
episodes of the hit Disney Channel revival.
"Family game night! My
favorite night of the month!"
A lot of actors who dominated TV
in the 1990s by virtue of starring
on a heavily watched network sitcom didn't
actually disappear from pop culture or quit
acting. They just moved into a niche
where their services are appreciated,
and their mere presence provides comfort and
nostalgia. Several former child stars and teen
actors from the 1990s and early 2000s nowadays
make a decent living and enjoy sizable followings
by starring in movies made specifically for
cable TV stations. This includes Savage.
In 2020, Savage headlined Love, Lights, Hanukkah!.
It's one of The Hallmark Channel's many holiday
romance movies and one of the few with
a non-Christmas theme. Two years later,
Savage broke out of his easy-going and
comedic wheelhouse with the Lifetime
original Girl in the Shed: The Kidnapping of
Abby Hernandez. In the true crime docudrama,
Savage portrayed real-life
kidnapper Nathaniel Kibby.
"My friends will kill your entire family."
Ben Savage is a seasoned
veteran of multiple television shows over the
decades, and so is Mandy Patinkin. As such,
Savage now fills a very specific niche
for TV producers — he's the guy to call
when a script calls for a younger version of
a Patinkin character in a flashback sequence.
In the second-to-last episode of Criminal Minds,
which aired in 2020, Savage played Jason Gideon,
Patinkin's character from the series, in
some scenes set in the distant past. Then,
just a couple of months later, Savage
guest-starred on Homeland as the younger,
past version of Saul Berenson, who is played in
the present day of the series by Mandy Patinkin.
Homeland co-creator Alex Gansa told TVLine,
"There was some talk of trying to
make Mandy, who is 67 in real life,
look like he was in his late 20s. But we did
some tests and it just wasn't believable."
After dismissing the idea of hiring
one of Patinkin's real-life sons,
Gansa learned that Savage had
played a younger version of a
Patinkin character on Criminal Minds and
reached out. Gansa said of the decision,
"He just bears such an
uncanny resemblance to Mandy."
Not in the public eye as much as he once was,
actor Ben Savage has valued his privacy and
his time out of the spotlight, choosing to
cultivate personal relationships with that
de facto freedom. He embraced living a life
not under constant scrutiny and developed a
romantic relationship that he kept virtually
secret for four years. According to People,
Savage quietly began dating Tessa Angermeier in
2018. About four years later, around Christmas
2022, the couple announced their engagement
in an Instagram photo. The photo was posted
on Savage's account as Angermeier has her account
on private. They'd only occasionally appeared in
public together, but Angermeier was present for
Savage's campaign events while running for West
Hollywood City Council in 2022. In a written
statement, Savage's representative told People,
"They are both very grateful and enjoying this
exciting time with their families and friends."
Ben Savage isn't as exceptionally busy
as he once was with his acting career,
which gives him the time and energy to
pursue other passions. In his college days,
Savage served as an intern in the Washington,
D.C. office of Pennsylvania senator Arlen
Specter and decades later, in 2022, he ran for
office himself. Savage vied for a seat on the
city council in West Hollywood, California,
where he'd lived for nearly two decades,
according to his campaign website. When all
the votes were tallied, Savage didn't win
one of the open seats on the board. According
to the Los Angeles County Registrar-Recorder,
Savage finished in sixth place out of 12
candidates, garnering 6.32% of all ballots cost.
Undeterred, months later Savage officially
set his sights on a higher federal office.
In January 2023, Savage announced that he'd
filed with the Federal Elections Commission
to run as a Democrat in California's 30th House
District in the U.S. House of Representatives,
a seat set to be vacated when Rep. Adam Schiff
leaves to run in a U.S. Senate election.